il y a comme dirait martine aubry le
flou et le
le flou c'est l'ump
le loup c'est le front national
l'ump n'a ni
au programme départemental
nice ap j ai cette élection est
seulement pour nicolas sarkozy
un moyen de prendre un peu d'avancé dans
la campagne interne de l'ump pour
l'élection présidentielle
nicolas sarkozy vient de lancer la
campagne départementale dans un
interview au fidjien sa formation
politique évidemment pas un
pas une proposition pour les
départements
l'amnésie
pour sa gestion passée
l'année me pour la nuit dans de la
france mais pour le présent rien
l'ump dans les départements
les candidats et les élus a picture
ont-ils les 100 milliards d'euros de
réduction budgétaire
voté pour l'ump c'est réduire les
départements à la portion congrue
il ne s'agit pas de faire participer
chacun à l'effort il s'agit d' une
véritable saignée
comment faire face à ce programme de
l'ump qui se propose de réduire de 600
mille à un million de fonctionnaires
écoles hôpitaux police toute la fonction
publique y passe et il faut dès
maintenant faire reculer cette offensive
qui mineraient notre cohésion sociale et
affaiblirait la république sans
moderniser l'économie
mais la stratégie est aussi en cause
nicolas sarkozy vient de lancer le fn ps
passons sur le fait que l'ex président
met sur le même plan un parti
républicain et un parti d'extrême droite
passons sur le fait qu'il s'agit avant
tout pour lui de se démarquer d'alain
juppé qui lui refuse de mettre sur le
même pied le front national le parti
socialiste mais c'est un aveu de panique
la direction de l'ump constate que son
électorat fils au front national au
premier tour
après avoir ouvert la porte au front
national par ses bruits sonnerie
l'apprenti sorcier ne sait plus comment
écopé si je puis dire et c'est
précisément
l'absence de consignes claires
j'y mets le front national au coeur de
la campagne
car si le parti socialiste et l'ump
pratiquer le désistement républicain
nulle part
le front national pourrait l'emporter
il suffit d'observer les élections
législatives partielles le parti
socialiste a party a pratiqué le
désistement républicain est nulle part
le front national les passer
et pour cela il faut appliquer appeler
un chat un chat et refuser d'aller
braconner sur les terres du front
national
et aujourd'hui nicolas sarkozy dit d'une
barre toute alliance avec le front
national vous vaudra exclusion ce qui
sous-entend que toute alliance avec le
ps ne le produira pas
et nicolas sarkozy qui d'autre part
qu'il maintiendra le ni ni ni ps ni
front national alors
fin du ni ni avec exclusion de ceux qui
s'allierait avec le nationale n'est pas
avec le ps ou continuité nul ne sait ce
flou des armes la droite républicaine
qui courent après
comment comprendre autrement les
attaques de monsieur darmanin contre
madame rousseau vieira
appelons-la appelons là aussi un chat un
chat dire que madame taubira est un
tract ondulant pour le front national
ce n'est pas critiquer sa politique
ces critiques et son être ces critiques
et son essence elle est noire
donc un tract en blanc pour le front
national qui est raciste voilà ce titre